so I'll start by asking you both about
working with James because you both did
uh the harder they fall so you know how
talented he is but is there anything you
saw him do in the book of Claren set
that made you go like damn I knew you
were good but not that good I I feel
like I've
already I've known he's that good like
James when it comes to how great he is
right it doesn't surprise me you feel me
it would surprise me if James
slept that that would surprise me yeah
if James actually took a rest day that
would be the only surprising thing but I
think what would be surprising I most
surprising thing was what um yeah I
think uh for for me I think uh you know
there were a lot of heavy moments that I
had where you know I can be pretty
serious about my approach to work so I
kind of find myself in just this like
really focused Mist um and he would
break me out of it in certain moments
with levity and comedy and ways that
made me just feel like remember it's fun
you know remember to have fun and uh
that was something that was really quite
special uh one time he one time he came
up to me and just randomly you know I
was just like in this mode he was like I
cost the wrong
Jesus but it is like pointed at me like
you know so it's quite funny I always
appreciate a little levity on a set cuz
these Productions are not easy to pull
off so you kind of need that does he
have a monitor dance is there something
you can catch him doing behind the
monitor that signals to you he is like
really digging a
take um I think it's not even like a
move it's a facial expression cuz James
already has like a very sh expression on
like yeah you can do it this is it but
when he's watching and he's enamored
right he turns into a kid and then he's
watching film that makes him happy on
the inside once he sees then he's
like hard hard he doesn't even say cut
cuz James doesn't believe in cutting the
creativity right he'll just let the
scene go and then let us end it as is
right but once it's you can hear
sometimes even when he goes too fast
hard I'm sorry yeah we're in the middle
of the scene hard hard just like wait
wait we're still filming exactly I'm
crying hard no James no is that always
how he's worked without saying cut at
the end and and if so what do you to
appreciate about that and maybe do you
wish more directors didn't say cut yes
yeah I like a little extra room uh
that's where happy accidents can happen
um and I just like you know to have a
little bit of extra space cuz you just
never know what's going to come up and
so it's a beautiful thing I really like
it and he has his own style it's very
much like my approach to acting it's
like your own style that you sort of
built uh over time through our
experiences in your life you know you
just bring it to the work so it's great
but I Al I also feel like all directors
might not be able to handle that freedom
of directing you feel me because James
when it comes to the full picture of the
film he already has it so he can allow
for us to be in that space he knows what
to do with every single piece of film
that he takes even the outakes he can
make a movie out of and it takes it
takes a dangerous person to be able to
do that and James is that person so like
it it's it's going to be hard but
there's there's I don't think there's
nobody that can do it like that
like that's the first time I've dealt
with a director that didn't use cut you
know that just allows for it to be you
cut the scene because you might give me
something that I didn't see before that
takes a different type of director yeah
to each their own every process is
different that that really intrigues and
excites me I feel like the creative
possibilities of someone operating that
way makes it just absolutely endless
yeah yeah exactly so now I have to ask
you two about working with each other I
love asking about the value of a good
scene partner especially when your
relationship is a big part of the
Beating Heart of this film so can you
each tell me something about the other
you appreciated as a scene partner maybe
something that even helped you access
something in your own character that you
wouldn't have been able to without him I
really love how Fearless RJ is as a
performer I think it's really important
to push the boundaries but that can be a
very scary thing and uh you don't want
to make mistakes um but there are these
performers who decide even in the face
of that I'm going to go for it and it
makes it very very fun keeps it very
interesting and he's so naturally funny
and he's naturally funny because he's
smart because you're you don't you don't
become that funny you know not being
able to pick up on things and not being
able to put things and misplace things
on purpose because that's what makes it
funny um and he's very good at that so
it was really just a joy and I was just
talking about how his countenance on set
was always just so Placid so cool so
never a problem he he never had a
problem with anything it could be the
most intense scene and he was just like
yeah all right hey we we cool how you
doing brother how you doing man love you
man so it was a real dope camaraderie
was dope cool quality to have yeah I
think something I've noticed noticed
excuse me about Lei throughout multiple
times that we've worked together um I've
always been like a fan of his work right
and I've always wanted to kind of be
able to bounce back and work that way
right and so we met what it was a bit
ago on the first film and then the heart
of they fall I was able to you know
actually link and make that scene
connection right so as a scene partner L
kind of opened my eyes to what it was to
fully sink into my characters right so
there's a certain person that leef
doesn't allow on set he lets the
character live there you feel me like
literally lets the character live so
when you're in the the scene right all
of your mistakes aren't mistakes they're
just another spark of your mind that you
you know you didn't have before and
he'll lean into it you feel me most
actors you know they can't play they
can't bounce you know unless they have a
structure to it which is okay but Le
kind of strengthens that to where you
can now come off so authentic you feel
me because I be overthinking sometime I
ain't going to lie I do but then when I
watch how he approaches in Freedom and
that's in every one of his roles you
know as you know his resume all of them
are Heavy Hitters you know he's like a
Mike Tyson in his acting thing you know
he always swings hard so to be in a
scene with a partner that supports your
hard swings or will tell you hey you're
not swinging hard enough swing harder
you feel me like he gives me the Praises
for my you know relentlessness and my my
risk taking right but he as that person
will bring that out of you because he
doesn't make it you know it's like okay
you messed up on that line say it the
same way don't you know please give me
that because now I have another idea
that I can use so if you don't give me
that we a't goingon to be able to see
what that idea is you know like you need
that in the scene partner one that
doesn't kind of get mad when you go off
or whatever they just know how to do
this sh you know he's that sharp so I
can say llama at a time where he's
emotional llama and it was a llama for
me llamas llamas you know that
that's fun that's play you know that's
Mastery of your beautiful answers to
that question I I love the idea of
mistakes not being mistakes your team is
as strong as the players and really
we're a team and we're trying to achieve
the same thing so it's like how do we
play off of each other how do we make it
work there are no mistakes just like in
real life if you do something you
accidentally drop something it's just it
just dropped it and you just got to pick
it up you know what I mean so so yeah
it's fun a movie like this doesn't come
to screen as successfully unless you
have that team mentality everybody
getting behind the Vision together and
not holding back in the least and you
guys pull it off brilliantly
congratulations thank
you